in this video we'll talk about the spino
cerebellar ataxia
spino cellular Ataxia or SCA is a group
of genetic disorders that primarily
affect the cerebellum and to a lesser
extent the spinal cord
in this condition there is a progressive
degeneration of the cerebellum now
cerebellum controls the movement
coordination balance Etc so obviously
anybody can understand there is a
problem regarding the balance and motor
coordination
also there is death of the cerebellar
neurons due to specific reason
in this video we'll try to review the
key points regarding cerebellar Ataxia
and then expand on them so cerebellar
Ataxia or spino cerebellar Ataxia
involves Progressive degeneration of the
cerebellum the progressive word is
important then the symptoms include
impaired coordination especially the
motor gate balance issues Tremors pitch
difficulties Etc then diagnosis involves
genetic testing clinical evaluation
sometimes MRI and imaging the management
focuses on the symptoms and they can try
to relieve the symptom and manage their
life with supportive cares like physical
therapy to improve the quality of life
then genetic counseling is required to
analyze the risk for the further
generation and ongoing research is
exploring the potential therapy
especially the genetic Therapies
so let's begin and try to break it down
step by step clinical presentation of
spino cerebral Ataxia includes
the problem with motor coordination
because the cerebellum is degenerating
the neurons are dying it would
eventually lead to Ataxia because
cerebellum is the portion of the brain
that controls coordination and balance
now in this case unsteady gait slurry
speech clumsiness difficulties with fine
motor skills let's say maneuvering
something with hand or painting
or this kind of fine-tuning aspect of
motorist coordination is abrogated also
there is involuntary eye movement known
as nystagmus
other features includes basically gate
instability Lim incoordination dysartria
heart related problems Tremor ocular
abnormalities dysphagia that means
speech difficulties overall
and there are other aspects which are
non-motor manifestations which lead to
overall cognitive declinement the
psychiatric symptoms and sometimes
peripheral neuropathy but for every
patient the symptoms are not same also
the extent of defects are also not same
this is something to understand then
let's talk about the genetic aspects of
spinous cerebral lure ataxia
so the genetics of spinous cerebral
Ataxia is interesting because there are
several genes which are involved in this
disease and these gene mutations are
categorized as sca1 sca2 up till sca37
and many more
so let's say which genes are mutated one
of the gene that is highly mutated is
attacks in one or atxn1
and there is one kind of mutation that
happens there is multi multiplication of
these cha repeats in a moment it would
be clear why this is detrimental but
anyway other than attacks in genes there
are other genes like ccna1
ppp2r2b dab one Etc all of these
regulates aspects of nerve nerve system
physiology
let's talk about the prevalence of this
genetic mutation in a global landscape
so different kind of mutations are
prevalent in different parts of the
world and this is sourced from a article
which is provided in the description as
well
now question is where are these
mutations located on the gene are they
present in the coding exons introns utrs
where it turns out it's pretty much
dispersed in different locations of the
gene there are many mutations which are
present in the coding Exon obviously it
would abrogate with the protein
production there are also mutations in
the utrs that means it can also alter
the gene expression regulation
now let's talk about the pathology of
spinal cerebellar ataxia in bit more
details so obviously we know the
sequence CAG eventually codes for
glutamine in spino cerebellar Ataxia
there are multiple CAG repeats but why
is that bad now in spino cerebral Ataxia
there are multiple glutamine in
basically in repeats so that is why it
is known as poly Q Disease by but why
poly Q is toxic for the cells
so there are many aspects everything is
not clear but some aspects are revealed
by extensive research so this is a
normal protein and this is a protein
with poly Q repeats in this case there
are specific uh binding Partners which
might
bind with these polyq regions and
eventually lead to its aggregation
also it can alter the bioenergetics
overall it can lead to ION channel
dysfunctions it can lead to RNA binding
protein binding to a specific location
nuclear inclusions are New Concept that
can lead to a problem in gene expression
as well
so overall there could be a toxicity in
RNA metabolism
there is transcriptional dysregulation
and DNA damage which are associated as
well but as I mentioned earlier all
these symptoms doesn't happen all
together some aspects of is true for
some different individuals now
channelopathies are pretty common in
spino cerebellar Ataxia voltage-gated
sodium and potassium Channel calcium
dependent potassium channels glutamate
receptors and voltage-gated calcium
channels are abrogated or their
functionality is abrogated in this
disease
when it comes to diagnosis of spinous
cerebral Ataxia MRI is one of the key
screening thing to do at first because
there is a cerebellar degeneration right
here you can see the cerebellum and in
the spinosity Builder Ataxia patient you
can see the dramatic change in the
cerebellar architecture alongside these
clinical Imaging data there should be
gate examination and other neurological
examinations family history taking and
most importantly the genetic testing
because it would give you a quick idea
that okay which particular Gene is
actually mutated what type of mutation
it is so high throughput sequencing is
the next future for diagnosis of several
disease including spino cerebellar
ataxia
now let's talk about the treatment
options for spinal cerebellar Ataxia
managing the symptoms is and giving
supportive care is the key management
there is no cure for this disease but
supportive treatment can improvise
lifestyle
this includes physical therapy speech
therapy genetic counseling and
supportive medication that can give you
overall cognitive boost
so I hope this was useful if you like
this video give it a quick thumbs up you
can follow us on Facebook and Instagram
for free notes you can support our
Channel using super thanks you can pay
via paytm PayPal or UPI see you in next
video